Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件现在正在发生、非常让人激动的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间去换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“冲刺持续性收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有志成为心理学家的人、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, we are looking
这些原则都对你适用。此次挑战赛还有丽莎本人亲自送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一交流一小时的辅导机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。快去我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent）查看，或者浏览我的社交媒体账号，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。在今天的《有志心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）中，我们将探讨
at failures. We are looking at all of the ways that things have not gone to plan for me in psychology. This might well resonate with you for a variety of reasons, personal and professional, but really want to inspire you to know that whatever you're going through now or whatever you've been through in the past doesn't mean that you can't still be a wonderful mental health professional i hope you find this episode so useful if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist.
失败。我们将回顾我在心理学道路上所有事情没有按计划发展的时刻。出于各种个人和职业原因，这很可能会引起你的共鸣；但真心希望能够通过这期节目激励你明白：无论你现在正在经历什么，或者过去经历过什么，这并不意味着你不能成为一名优秀的心理健康专业人士。如果你正准备成为一名心理学家，我希望这期节目对你大有裨益，并让它成为你的指南。嗨，欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。
If you are listening to this episode when it is first available, then you might well be aware that if you are an aspiring educational psychologist, that the deadline for applications for this year is looming. It is Wednesday, the 29th of November 2023. So that is imminent. That is this week, if you're listening to this on Monday. And if you are an aspiring clinical psychologist and you're planning on applying this year, then I hope you've already done it because the deadline for that was Wednesday the 22nd of November. So I hope that went really well for you if you did apply and there will be episodes coming soon about what you can do between now and when we start to hear about shortlists. I thought it would be a really nice chance to think today about when things don't
如果你在节目刚上线时就收听了，你可能很清楚，如果你是一位有志成为教育心理学家的人，今年申请的截止日期已经迫在眉睫了。今天是2023年11月29日，星期三。所以时间非常紧迫。如果你是在周一收听这期节目，那截止日期就是本周。如果你是一位有志成为临床心理学家的朋友，并计划今年申请，那我希望你已经完成了，因为申请截止日期是11月22日星期三。所以，如果你已经申请了，我希望一切都非常顺利。接下来很快会有节目讨论，在现在到我们开始听到入围名单通知这段时间里，你可以做些什么。我想今天是一个非常好的机会，来思考当事情没有
go to plan because that is life isn't it and we often I, don't talk enough about the things that we haven't done very well, felt like failure at the time, and might even have come with a big F, fail stamp. So others may also have regarded it as failure. And why I think this is important as a narrative is because it helps us with our reflecting, it helps us with our reflecting, it helps us with our growth, it also helps normalise some of the struggles that are around for us in our career, both as aspiring mental health professionals and qualified ones too. If you think I sound a little bit gruff, I've had a little bit of a cough hanging around in the background. So I'll make sure that my podcast editor edits out any hacking coughs that happen. In case you're listening on MP3 and you're like, she sounds different. That's why. Okay, so let's think in no particular order
按照计划发展时该怎么办，因为这就是生活，不是吗？而且我们通常——我——对于那些我们做得不够好、当时感觉像失败、甚至可能被打上了大大的“F”（失败）印记的事情，谈论得还不够多。所以别人也可能认为那是失败。为什么我认为这个经历分享很重要？因为它有助于我们进行反思，有助于我们进行反思，有助于我们的成长，它还有助于让我们在职业生涯中遇到的一些挣扎变得正常化，无论是对于有志于成为心理健康专业人士的人，还是已经获得资格的专业人士来说都是如此。如果你觉得我的声音听起来有点沙哑，那是因为我有一点咳嗽还没完全好。所以我一定会让我的播客剪辑师把任何激烈的咳嗽声都剪掉。以防你是在听 MP3，并且觉得：她听起来怎么不太一样。原因就在这里。好吧，那么让我们按随机顺序列举
about one of the first ways that I have failed in psychology. So the first of the ways is that I got three C's and a D for my A levels. Now, technically not a fail, but bearing in mind, my GCSEs were much better than that. I think I fell below my own expectations. And I think there's a variety of reasons for that. So I worked really, really hard at school for year seven, year eight, and year nine. And enough of knuckling down and doing all my homework and doing all my extra reading. I think I burned myself out a little bit. So when it came to GCSEs, I probably had a bit more fun with my friends. I definitely took my foot off the accelerator pedal, but I still managed to do pretty well for my GCSEs. I think I got one A star, three A's, five B's and a C. So, you know, pretty reasonable.
我在心理学道路上的第一次失败经历。那么第一种失败是，我的 A-level（高级水平考试）成绩得了三个 C 和一个 D。现在严格来说这不算不及格，但考虑到我的 GCSE（普通中等教育证书）成绩比这好得多，我觉得我的表现低于了自己的预期。我认为这有各种各样的原因。所以我在学校的七年级、八年级和九年级时真的非常非常努力。后来我就不再那么死记硬背、做所有家庭作业和进行所有课外阅读了。我觉得自己有点精疲力竭了。所以在考 GCSE 的时候，我可能和朋友们有了更多乐趣。我绝对是把脚从油门踏板上松开了，但我设法在 GCSE 中取得了相当不错的成绩。我想我得到了一个 A 星、三个 A、五个 B 和一个 C，所以，你知道，相当合理。
And I think that then lulled me into a false sense of security when it came to my A levels. I thought I could coast through again. But what I probably hadn't appreciated was that the core subjects I was studying at GCSE, I'd probably put in all the legwork for in my very conscientious year seven, eight and nine. And of course, I still went to the lessons and did the homework that I had to do I think that was enough to carry me through reasonably well for GCSEs and for my maths I did ask for extra help so me and my friend went and did extra help probably a bit late if I'd done that for the coursework element I think I might well have got an A or an A star for maths, whereas in the end I got a B. But yeah, I think what I needed was probably for the teachers to not have taken their eye off me and to have thought I was probably a reasonably safe bet. I think I needed some accountability.
我想这让我对 A-level 产生了一种虚假的安全感。我以为自己可以再次轻轻松松地通过。但我当时可能没有意识到的是，我在 GCSE 学习的核心科目，我可能在我非常认真的七、八、九年级时就已经把基础工作都做扎实了。当然，我还是去上课并完成了必须做的作业。我认为这足以让我相当顺利地通过 GCSE。至于数学，我的确请求了额外的帮助，所以我和朋友去寻求了额外的帮助，可能稍微有点晚了。如果我把这用在课程作业部分，我想我数学可能会得 A 或 A 星，而最后我得了 B。但是，是的，我觉得我需要的是老师们没有把视线从我身上移开，并认为我可能是一个比较稳妥的人。我觉得我需要一些监督和问责。
So I used to just use my study sessions to go and hang out, sometimes have a little nap at school. So we had to be at school in those days during study periods, but we weren't held accountable for what we did. So I remember for my biology A-level, which I did, we had these really lovely books. They weren't that thick. They were quite thin. And it was kind of one module at a time. And really, all I needed to have done to have got a really good grade was to read that book, probably lesson by lesson,
所以我过去常常只用自习时间去闲逛，有时在学校小睡一会儿。所以那个年代我们在自习课期间必须待在学校，但没有人监督我们到底做了什么。所以我记得对于我参加的生物学 A-level 考试，我们有这些非常可爱的书。它们不是那么厚。它们相当薄。而且基本上是一次学一个模块。实际上，为了取得好成绩，我真正需要做的就是阅读那本书，可能是一课接一课地读，
and then maybe take a few notes on it. This might be a good chance to talk about the better ways of educating and preparing for exams, which you can find by checking out my YouTube. That's episode 65, and that came out on the 6th of March 2023. I think I would have found that really, really useful and really, really inspiring to let me know what I was doing wrong. But I would have benefited from a teacher just being there, you know, saying this is your free time, but, you know, you can use this for your reading. Come along, do that reading that you know you're not going to do if you're not here. I would have gone along and I would have got that done and I would have done much better whereas the complete lack of structure just meant that I took all my feet
然后也许记一些笔记。现在这或许是一个谈论更好的教育和备考方式的好机会，你可以在我的 YouTube 频道上找到相关内容。那是第 65 期节目，发布于 2023 年 3 月 6 日。我想我会发现那些内容非常、非常有用，也非常、非常鼓舞人心，能让我知道自己哪里做错了。但我如果能有一个老师就坐在那里，说“这是你的空闲时间，但你可以用它来阅读。过来，去做那些你知道如果不在这里就不会做的阅读”，我会从中受益匪浅。如果有人督促，我就会去把它做完，我会做得好得多。然而，完全缺乏结构意味着我把所有的脚
off all of the pedals I think and just coasted and so I think I've probably got some traits of ADHD so I think I did reasonably well when when I was being kind of ridden in GCSEs. But teachers very much give you the learning and the responsibility for learning at A-level. And they did in the late 90s as well, which is when I was doing my qualifications. And I needed more. I needed more accountability. And I think I probably could have created that had I asked for it. So that led to me getting a D in biology. It didn't alter the place I was offered at university. But had I been studying harder and more efficiently from the beginning, it might well have, you know, affected which university I chose.
都从踏板上拿开了吧，只是随波逐流。所以我想我可能有一些多动症（ADHD）的特质，因此当我在 GCSE 期间受到某种程度的“驾驭”时，我表现得还算不错。但是到了 A-level 阶段，老师们很大程度上把学习内容和学习责任都交给了你自己。在我 90 年代末参加考试时也是如此。而我需要更多。我需要更多的监督和问责。我想如果我开口要求的话，我本可以创造出这种环境。所以这导致我的生物学得了 D。它没有改变大学给我的录取通知书，但如果我从一开始就更努力、更有效率地学习，它很可能会影响我选择哪所大学。
It may not have done and it all still ended up okay. But that's what I would, that's where I think I failed in my A-levels. Okay. And the second thing I failed at, I'll level with you, is an almost failed. And it was when I was doing my doctorate in clinical psychology. There's an awful part in your mid-placement review where your personal tutor from the university turns to your placement supervisor and says, is there any chance that they might fail this placement? And on one occasion, the answer was yes. There's a whole backstory to this which is another episode which I don't feel was just I do feel we just had a mismatch of communication and I did end up passing that but it did lead to lots and lots of distress lots of self-doubt um lots and lots of distress, lots of self-doubt, lots and lots of difficulties that I did end up then getting some therapy for latterly. But yeah, you know, those were the words I heard
也许不会，而且最终一切都圆满解决了。但这就是我所认为的——我认为我在 A-level 中失败的地方。好的。我第二次失败的经历，跟你直说吧，是一次“差一点失败”。那是我在攻读临床心理学博士学位期间。在学期中期的实习评估中有一个可怕的环节，来自大学的个人导师转头问你的实习主管：“他们有没有可能无法通过这次实习？”其中有一次，回答是“是的”。这背后有一整段故事，那是另一期节目的内容。我觉得那并不公正——我的确觉得我们当时存在沟通不顺畅，最后我确实通过了那次实习。但这确实导致了非常非常多的痛苦、许多自我怀疑——
and it absolutely had an impact upon me, whether or not they were just or fair, another story. But they were said and I still had all the fields, um, all the stuff going on. And so, um, you know, it's big, it's important and people wield power over us. Um, and you know, absolutely. We've got, uh, our own responsibilities. We've got everything we bring to the party, but I did feel that was, um, a very challenging time in my life. So yeah, that was number two. Number three, I did actually fail a module in my undergraduate psychology. I think it was in year two. It might have been in year three. I think it was in year two and it was would you believe it it was an optional module so there was a free floating module where I could have picked anything for I
非常非常多的痛苦、许多自我怀疑，以及许许多多的困难，我后来为此接受了一些心理治疗。但是，是的，你知道，那些是我听到的话，它绝对对我产生了影响，不管它们是否公正或公平，那是另一回事。但这些话确实被说出来了，我内心依然经历着所有的情绪、所有的波折。所以，你知道，这很大，这很重要，而且人们对我们行使着权力。而且，你知道，当然，我们有我们自己的责任，我们带来了我们所有的一切，但我确实觉得那是——我生命中非常具有挑战性的一段时期。所以，是的，那是第二点。第三点，我在本科心理学学习期间其实挂过一门课。我想那是在大二。也可能是在大三。我想那是在大二，而且——你敢相信吗——那是一门选修课。所以那是一门自由支配的模块，我可以为——
think it was a for a semester and I really fancied maybe French or, you know, creative writing, which, you know, were things that I thought was a nice chance to do something as a little bit of bonus credit. But it doesn't necessarily need to be something psychology-ish. The problem being is that all the modules didn't coincide with the free time that I had available. And so I was sort of, it was suggested I do the suggested module on probability. And so I did. And some of my peers did that, some of them didn't. And I just didn't seem to be able to get it into my mind, what I was doing. And my friend sitting next to me ended up getting like, you know, basically an A star. She got everything right. I know, remember in the tests that we did, she got like a hundred
我想是一个学期选修任何东西。我真的很想学法语，或者，你知道，创意写作，我觉得这真是一个好机会，可以作为一点额外的学分来做点别的事情。但这不一定非得是心理学相关的内容。问题在于，所有的模块都和我当时拥有的空闲时间对不上。因此，有人建议我选修概率论这个模块。于是我就选了。我的一些同龄人选了，一些人没选。而我似乎就是无法把我在做什么弄进脑子里。坐在我身边的朋友最终考了——你知道，基本上是个 A 星。她全答对了。我知道，我记得在我们做的测试中，她考了差不多百分之
percent. And I was like, oh no, I'm really not understanding. I'm really not getting this. And when it came to the exam, I failed it. And so I had to have the experience of going into university during the summer term, which was like a two and a half hour trip each way to re-sit. And I don't know how I did it. I think I did some extra lessons with my brother, who was a pure maths student at university. And he, I think, coached me enough that I was able to just scrape a pass. But I don't quite know what I would have done if I didn't pass that. I think I probably would have had to pay to have done it again myself, but it didn't feel good. And it didn't feel good because it was an F, it was a fail and repeat and
百。而我当时想：哦不，我真的没懂。我真的搞不懂这个。到了考试的时候，我挂科了。所以我不得不经历在夏季学期去学校补考，单程要花两个半小时左右。我不知道我是怎么熬过来的。我想我和我哥哥一起上了几节额外的补习课，他当时在大学里学的是纯数学。我想他辅导我的程度刚好够让我勉强及格。但我真不知道如果我没通过那门考试我会怎么办。我想我可能不得不自己花钱重修，但这感觉真不好。这感觉不好不仅是因为它是个 F（不及格），意味着挂科、重修和
redo, but also because it was something I'd chosen. know I'd had some control in that I didn't technically need to take that module although I couldn't really find anything else to do so how much choice I had I'm not really sure but yes I did fail a module at university number four probably should have made this number three but it is number four, all the same. I failed my driving test. I only passed on the third attempt. The first time, I just don't think I was ready. The second time, I think I made a bit of a silly mistake. But the third time, I really thought my driving was all right. But what happened was because I went the wrong route, so the instructor wanted me to think go straight over. And I think I went, it's Milton Keynes, it's the land of roundabouts. I think I took like second left.
重考，还因为这是我自己的选择。我知道我对此有一定的控制权，虽然我技术上并不需要选那门课——尽管我也找不到别的可做，所以我究竟有多少选择权我其实不太确定——但无论如何，我在大学里确实挂过一门课。第四点，我本来应该把这个排在第三点的，但它同样是第四点。我考驾照挂了。我考了第三次才通过。第一次，我只是觉得我还没准备好。第二次，我觉得我犯了一个有点傻的错误。但第三次，我真的觉得我的驾驶技术已经很好了。但发生的事情是，因为我走错了路线——考官希望我直行通过，而我认为那是——那是米尔顿凯恩斯（Milton Keynes），那是环岛之城——我想我好像在第二个路口左转了。
I just thought, oh, I failed then. All right. So I just carried on doing the rest of the route, just thinking this is driving practice, if nothing else, and I'm paying for the car. I've paid for the test. And then I got to the test center and they said, well, I'm pleased to say that you've passed. And I was like, what do you mean I've passed? You know, I went wrong. I said, yes, but you indicated appropriately. So at the point where I thought I'd failed, I just relaxed and I just drove without any pressure. And then that allowed me to showcase
我当时想：好吧，那我这次肯定考砸了。所以我就继续开完剩下的路线，心想就算别的不管，这也是在练习开车，而且我已经付了车钱，付了考试费了。然后我到了考场，他们说：“嗯，我很高兴地告诉您，您通过了。”我当时就想：“你什么意思，我通过了？我走错路了啊。”他们说：“是的，但你正确地打了转向灯。”所以，在那个我认为自己已经失败的时刻，我反而放松了下来，在没有任何压力的情况下开车。这让我得以展示
my driving ability without any kind of panic. So yes, as long as you are telling them what you're going to do properly and then you do it doesn't matter what route you take um i didn't i did make it quite tricky for my driving instructor at the time who then had to find a different route for me to then go and do all the things i needed to do because they use different routes for different and for different candidates so that you're not doing the same route every time but yeah i did find it really challenging the first time i failed it really was a dent to my ego. And why is this relevant to psychology, I hear you ask?
我的驾驶能力，没有任何恐慌。所以，是的，只要你清楚地告诉他们你要做什么并正确执行，你走哪条路并不重要。这确实给当时的驾校教练增添了不少麻烦，他不得不为我重新规划一条路线，以便让我去完成所有需要做的事情。因为他们会为不同的考生使用不同的路线，这样你就不会每次都走同一条路线。但，是的，我第一次考挂的时候确实觉得非常具有挑战性，对我的自尊心是一个沉重的打击。你可能会问，这和心理学有什么关系？
Well, it's because for many roles in psychology, you need to be able to drive. Certainly for the doctorate in clinical psychology, driving is a prerequisite. You need to take your driving license with you to interviews sometimes to show that you can drive. And so this was key but I did manage to pass just at the end of my first year of undergrad and then it meant that I was able to take my car to uni and drive around take my friends to the supermarket and sometimes because we lived at the top of a big hill sometimes we'd just drive down the big hill and then drive back up it again um if it was raining which it did a lot in south wales um in those days fuel was really cheap as well um gone are those days um but yeah i did fail my driving test on the first two attempts um but i do think that learning to drive and having my driving license is one of the best skills that I have.
嗯，这是因为在心理学中的许多角色，你需要具备驾驶能力。对于临床心理学博士学位来说，驾驶绝对是一个先决条件。面试时有时需要你随身携带驾照以证明你能开车。所以这很关键。不过我总算在大一结束时通过了驾照考试，这意味着我可以把车开到大学去，四处兜风，带朋友去超市。有时因为我们住在山顶上，下雨的时候——那里的南威尔士（South Wales）当年经常下雨——我们就会直接把车开下大山，然后再开上去。那年头油费也很便宜，
It's meant I've been able to do so many wonderful things, both work, pleasure, family related. You know, I've driven in Thailand. I've driven in New Zealand, driven in Spain, you know, internationally, nationally. And I've just done wonderful, wonderful things because I can drive. You know, top memory of driving was when I was backpacking in 2003 in Australia and nobody else wanted to or could drive the 4x4 that we were using on Fraser Island, which is the largest sand island in the world. And so I did, me and my friend who I was backpacking with, we did all the driving and I loved it. It was so exciting, so cool, just like flooring it on a beach, like really, really cool. And I wouldn't have been able to do that if I couldn't drive. So it is absolutely a very important skill, I would say. But it's also meant that in some of the more junior
那种日子已经一去不复返了。但，是的，我前两次考驾照确实都挂了，但我确实认为学开车并拥有驾照是我拥有的最好技能之一。这意味着我能够做那么多精彩的事情，无论是工作、娱乐还是家庭相关的事情。你知道的，我在泰国开过车，在新西兰开过车，在西班牙开过车——无论是国际还是国内。我仅仅因为会开车，就做了很多非常非常棒的事情。你知道，关于开车最美好的记忆是 2003 年我在澳大利亚背包旅行时，在弗雷泽岛（Fraser Island，世界最大的沙岛）上，没有其他人愿意或者能够驾驶我们正在使用的四驱车。所以我和一起背包旅行的朋友包揽了所有的驾驶，我太喜欢了。太刺激了，太酷了，就像在沙滩上全速驰骋一样，真的非常非常酷。如果我不会开车，我就不可能做到这一点。所以绝对是一项非常重要的技能，我要这么说。但这也意味着在我做的一些资历较浅、
kind of clinically relevant roles I did, like I was able to do home caring, I was able to do work in the community with people. And so it was really important to me in my psychology career as well. Number five, and this is the last one before we take a brief break, but I did actually fail an assignment on my doctorate in clinical psychology. And I think there's a variety of reasons for this. It was the second presentation that I had to do. I think it was in my third year. I think I felt a bit like I'd done so well in the presentation that I did that was number one that I got a little bit complacent. I don't think I was super happy about the topic I was doing, but because it was a topic that I felt like I knew a great deal about because of the work that I'd done.
与临床相关的岗位上，比如我能够做居家护理，我能够在社区里和人们一起工作。所以这在我的心理学职业生涯中也非常重要。第五点，这也是我们短暂休息前的最后一个失败，但在临床心理学博士学位期间，我其实挂过一次作业。我认为这有各种各样的原因。那是我必须做的第二个演讲。我想那是在我大三的时候。我觉得自己好像因为第一个演讲做得太好，导致我有点自满。我觉得我对正在做的这个主题并不是超级满意，但因为这是一个我觉得自己通过以前做过的工作已经了解很多的领域——
It was on physical health. I think it was on multiple sclerosis and I felt like I knew quite a lot about it already. So I think I didn't do enough prep and I think I felt that the teacher that was going to be assessing it, I think I felt they were so nice that they wouldn't be critical and they wouldn't fail me. I don't think I realized it was really possible to fail a presentation because I'm good at presentations, but I did fail it nonetheless. And I I had to resubmit I think it was just a few tweaks I don't think I had to do the whole presentation again but you know the learning points here are make sure you're giving assignments and exams the necessary prep and legwork that you need make sure you're looking at your essential criteria that you need to be
那是关于身体健康的。我想那是关于多发性硬化症（multiple sclerosis）的，我觉得自己对它已经相当了解了。所以我想我没有做足够的准备，而且我觉得将要评估它的老师人非常好，不会太挑剔，也不会让我挂科。我当时并不觉得挂掉一个演讲是真的可能的，因为我擅长演讲，但我还是挂了。而且——我不得不重新提交。我想那只是需要做一些微调，我觉得我不需要重新做整个演讲，但这里的学习要点是：确保你为作业和考试投入了必要的准备工作和基础功夫；确保你查看了你需要
demonstrating. Don't be, you know, don't be overly confident, you know, go into things, you know, giving them the due respect that they, you know, that they deserve is my learning point. You know, this is a doctoral level qualification. I should have been putting in doctoral level effort into all of the assignments. So yeah, you know, do better, Marianne was the answer. And thankfully, that was then passed. But it didn't feel very nice, but it is common. People will often fail at least one assignment on their doctorate courses. And life or contextual factors going on, you can ask for an extension as well. If you don't hand it in on time, obviously, and you haven't asked let's use this time here now to take a short break. And I'll be back along very soon. Thank you. Welcome back along. In the first half of the episode, we were looking at my first five ways that I have failed in psychology. I've still got loads more to share with you and I really want to have these conversations so that we normalize that getting things A, starred and right first time are not essential and not par for the course either. Let's look at number six and it may not feel that psychological but I would class a serious relationship fail
展示的基本标准。不要——你知道，不要过于自信，去做事情时要给予它们应有的尊重——这就是我的学习点。你知道，这是博士级别的资格。我应该在所有的作业中都投入博士级别的努力。所以，是的，“玛丽安，你得做得更好”就是答案。谢天谢地，那次作业后来通过了。但这感觉很不好，不过这也是常见的。人们在博士课程中通常至少会挂掉一次作业。如果生活中或情境中发生了什么事情，你也可以申请延期。如果你没有按时交作业，当然也没有提前申请的话——让我们利用现在这段时间休息一下。我很快就会回来。谢谢。欢迎回来。在节目的前半部分，我们探讨了我进入心理学领域以来的前五种失败方式。我还有很多要和大家分享，我真的很想进行这些交流，以便让我们认识到：门门拿 A 星、第一次就完全正确既不是必需的，也不是常态。让我们来看看第六点。这可能听起来不那么像心理学，但我会将一段严重失败的感情
as being psychology related so it was heartbreaking it was my choice but I do feel that my psychology career was partly because of that because I hoped I was going to be going away to a university town or city to go and study I didn't know where that was going to be but I knew that was the direction that I wanted my life to go in and I just wasn't entirely convinced that that was going to necessarily be possible in that relationship. And there's obviously a variety of reasons involved. But yeah, there might well be heartbreak and relationship breakdowns on your journey. And it's also pretty common when people get onto doctorate training that they might be some relationship breakdowns too. Sometimes it's called the divorce course
因为与心理学有关，所以这让人心碎。这是我的选择，但我确实觉得我选择心理学职业部分是因为这个，因为我希望去一个大学镇或城市去学习，我不知道那会是哪里，但我知道这是我希望生活前进的方向，我只是不完全确信这段关系中一定能实现这一点。这其中显然有各种各样的原因。但是的，在你的旅程中很可能会遇到心碎和关系破裂。当人们开始攻读博士学位时，关系破裂也是很常见的。有时它被称为离婚课程
and there will be an episode coming on that in future too. Number seven is that I actually only got a low 2.1 at university. So I did then go on to do master's level study to evidence that I could do it. But I think it was some of the same old, same old from my A levels, which meant that I wasn't applying myself. I was certainly, I would say, more than our my university housemates were especially in the final year because um well i think she would say herself the only other person in the in my house who was actually in her final year didn't really care she was doing media um and she wasn't really that bothered um whereas uh my other friend she had changed courses after year one and so she was actually only in her second year when i was in my third year
未来也会有一期关于这个话题的节目。第七点是，我上大学时实际上只拿了一个很低的二级甲等学位（2.1）。所以我后来去读了硕士水平的课程来证明我能做到。但我认为这其中有些是我A-level时期的老毛病，这意味着我没有全力以赴。我肯定会说，比我的大学室友们付出得更多，尤其是在最后一年，因为呃，我想她自己也会说，我宿舍里另一个真正在读大四的人其实根本不在乎，她学的是传媒，她其实没那么上心，而我的另一个朋友在一年级后换了专业，所以当我读大三时，她实际上只读大二
and then i was living with two irish guys who mainly just had lots and lots of fun um i don't know what work they did if any so. So when I was needing to study, I was sometimes having to say, no, I can't come out. I can't do these things because I need to study. But of course, if there'd been, it's not my housemates fault, it absolutely isn't. But if there'd been more people studying and less exciting things happening, and I'd been less impulsive, then I might well have done more studying. But there was actually another relationship breakdown during my final year. And I think had I not had the relationship breakdown, I probably just would have wanted to spend all my time with him. And so I may not have even got the low 2-1,
然后我和两个爱尔兰男生住在一起，他们主要就是玩得很开心，我不知道他们做过什么工作（如果有的话）。所以当我需要学习时，有时我不得不说，不，我不能出去。我不能做这些事情，因为我需要学习。但当然，如果有的话，这并不是我室友的错，绝对不是。但如果有更多人在学习，有更少令人兴奋的事情发生，而且我没那么冲动的话，我可能就会花更多时间学习了。但事实上，在我大四期间又发生了一次关系破裂。我想如果我没有经历那次关系破裂，我可能只想把所有时间都花在他身上，所以我甚至可能都拿不到那个较低的二级甲等学位，
which then would have meant a very different career experience for me. So with hindsight, I'm kind of pleased that that happened. But at the time, that was also really, really, really challenging. But, yeah, I think I would have benefited from more accountability. When I was getting my assignments back at university in my first year, second year and third year, they weren't what I was expecting. The grades weren't as good as I expected. And actually what I think I should have done was I should have reached out to the Student Support Learning Centre and got some more support and guidance and all the lecturers, you know, how can I do better? But I think a little bit of pride got
那对我的职业生涯来说就会是一次截然不同的体验了。所以事后看来，我有点庆幸事情会这样发展。但在当时，这也是非常非常具有挑战性的。不过，是的，我觉得如果能有更多的监督和责任感，我会受益匪浅。当我在大学一年级、二年级和三年级拿到作业时，结果并不是我预期的。成绩没有我预期的那么好。实际上我认为我应该做的是，我应该向学生支持学习中心寻求更多的支持和指导，还有所有的讲师，你知道的，我该如何做得更好？但我认为有一点自尊心作祟
in the way, a bit of embarrassment. I didn't do that, but that's absolutely what I should have done. And I think it's probably some of the same old from when I was at secondary school, I was used to doing well. And I didn't seem to be doing as well as I hoped to or thought I could. And I should have asked for more help. So some more accountability for some more structure. So thankfully, I did get my low to one. But, you know, I think I was probably capable of more. So, yes, I've sort of ended up saying two points in one there because not asking for help at uni was my next point. But I think it's related, isn't it? So, yeah, if you're not getting the results that you think that you should be or that you think you're capable of or, you know, all of your peers seem to be finding it much more effortless than you are,
挡了路，有点尴尬。我没有那样做，但这绝对是我当时应该做的。我想这可能和我中学时的一些老毛病有关，我习惯了表现出色。而我当时的表现似乎不如我希望的那么好，也不如我认为自己能做到的那样好。我本该寻求更多帮助。所以需要更多的监督和更多的结构。值得庆幸的是，我确实拿到了我那较低的二级甲等学位。但是，你知道，我觉得我可能具备更多的潜力。所以，是的，我最后把两点合为了一点，因为在大学里不求助就是我的下一个要点。但我想这两者是有联系的，不是吗？所以，是的，如果你没有得到你认为自己应该得到的、或者你觉得自己有能力达到的结果，或者，你知道的，你所有的同龄人都觉得这一切比你轻松得多，
do ask for help. There is no shame in asking for help. I wish I had because it's much better to feel like you're comfortably within your window of tolerance, your zone of excellence, rather than feeling like you're really trying hard and you're not meeting the standards. So please, if you are not getting the results that you're expecting, please do ask for help. And last but not least, I mean, there might well be loads more, but these are the ones that I could think about, was that of all the jobs I applied to, there were many, many aspiring psychologist jobs that I didn't even get shortlisted for, or I got interviews for, but I wasn't appointed to. Sometimes I was told, oh, you are our second choice, but they are the person has accepted the job but it's just so close but no cigar as the saying goes and I remember there was one time that I took that really personally so
一定要寻求帮助。寻求帮助并不可耻。我真希望自己当时求助了，因为感觉自己舒舒服服地处于耐受窗口和卓越区内，要远比觉得自己真的很努力却达不到标准要好得多。所以求求你们，如果没有得到预期的结果，请一定要寻求帮助。最后但并非最不重要的一点是，我的意思是，可能还有很多其他的事，但这些是我能想到的：在我申请的所有工作中，有很多很多有志成为心理学家的工作，我甚至连入围面试都没有得到，或者我得到了面试机会，但没有被录用。有时他们会告诉，哦，你是我们的第二选择，但是另一个人已经接受了工作，真的是差一点点，但正如俗话所说，差之毫厘谬以千里。我记得有一次我真的把这看得很个人，所以
it wasn't even an assistant psychologist role it was when I was living near Milton Keynes and it was for the Milton Keynes Community Foundation and I just felt that this job would be really really good for me and it felt you know like it was kind of clinically relevant because we're working with kind of lots of vulnerable populations and doing kind of lots of outreach work and I just felt this job would be a bit of me and I went to the interview and I was so excited I would have really really liked the job and then I remember going out to the theatre with friends that evening and I was sort of imagining how cool it would be to to work there and I felt like oh yeah you know I'd practiced saying what my job title was in my head and you know I felt like the interview had
这甚至都不是助理心理学家的职位，那是我住在米尔顿凯恩斯附近的时候，是为米尔顿凯恩斯社区基金会招聘的，我只是觉得这份工作对我真的非常非常好，而且感觉，你知道的，它有点像临床相关的工作，因为我们要与许多弱势群体合作，还要做很多外展工作，我就是觉得这份工作简直是为我量身定做的。我去参加了面试，我太兴奋了，我真的非常非常想要这份工作。然后我记得那天晚上和朋友们去看话剧，我还在想象在那里工作会是多么酷的一件事，我感觉，哦，是的，你知道的，我已经在我脑海里练习过说我的职位头衔了，而且（你知道的）我觉得面试
gone well and that that was going to be my new job so it was a surprise and a disappointment to learn that I didn't get the job um with the feedback being that we didn't feel like you knew enough about the um the Milton Keynes is built of lots of different estates on the grid we didn't feel like you knew enough about the different estates on the grid and the areas of deprivation that were around in Milton Keynes. Now, they were probably right. So although I'd grown up, you know, living and working in Milton Keynes, I probably didn't know enough at that stage. But what I would say is that the next job that I did get working for Milton Keynes Council was directly working in those areas of deprivation. So I did then develop a very good understanding, real empathy for the people that were living there. And I think I probably got the job I needed.
进行得很顺利，那将是我的新工作，所以得知自己没有得到这份工作时，我感到既惊讶又失望。得到的反馈是，我们觉得你对米尔顿凯恩斯的网格布局中由许多不同住宅区组成的特点了解得还不够深入，我们觉得你对米尔顿凯恩斯周边不同的住宅区以及贫困地区了解得不够多。现在看来，他们可能是对的。所以尽管我是在米尔顿凯恩斯长大、生活和工作的，但在那个阶段我可能确实了解得不够。但我要说的是，我接着做的下一份为米尔顿凯恩斯议会工作的工作，直接就是在那片贫困地区进行的。所以我随后确实对那里的人们有了很好的了解和真正的同理心。我想我大概是得到了我真正需要的工作。
So, you know, when I was when I was looking for qualified work, one of my peers said to me, what's for you doesn't pass you by. And I really, really held on to that. Because, yeah, I believe I got the job I needed ended up with me having a wonderful supervisor who's become a friend for life. I learned so much about myself, as well as about psychology in the next role that I got working with disabled adults. And I learned how to be human, how to, you know, do loads of really important tasks like budgeting, safeguarding, you know, motivation, you know, coming up against adversity, understanding about physical health, the challenges inherent in that, how to apply for benefits with people, you know, how to do activity scheduling. I did absolutely
所以，你知道的，当我寻找有资质的工作时，我的一个同行对我说：“属于你的终究是你的，不属于你的强求不来。”我真的把这句话牢牢记在心里。因为，是的，我相信我得到了我需要的工作，最终让我遇到了一位出色的主管，她成了我一生的朋友。在接下来的这份与残障成年人合作的工作中，我学到了很多关于自我以及心理学的知识。我学会了如何做一个有血有肉的人，如何，你知道的，做好大量非常重要的任务，比如预算管理、保障工作、激励他人，你知道的，如何面对逆境，理解身体健康及其内在的挑战，如何帮人们申请福利，你知道的，如何进行活动安排。我绝对做了
loads. So I absolutely got the job that I needed to then get me, you know, two and a half years, I think I was there for, to then be able to get assistant psychologist roles but yeah I didn't get quite a few roles there was even qualified roles I didn't get the tricky thing being when I graduated in 2011 was that we were in the recession and there were no jobs and so there were lots and lots of people going for not many jobs so there was a probably three or four interviews I had that I didn't get before I then did get my CAMHS job and that was tricky because you know I needed a job I had a mortgage but I did end up being out of work for a couple of months but I still think that was great and it gave me time to decompress from the university experience and to transition myself from being
超级多。所以我的确得到了我需要的工作，然后让我在那里呆了大约两年半的时间，接着就能去争取助理心理学家的职位了。不过，是的，我确实没有得到好几个职位，甚至还有一些有资质的职位我也没能拿到。2011年我毕业时棘手的情况是，我们正处于经济衰退期，没有工作可做，所以有大量的人去竞争为数不多的岗位。在我最终得到儿童及青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）的工作之前，我大概经历了三四次没有成功的面试。这很棘手，因为，你知道的，我需要一份工作，我还有房贷，但我最终确实失业了几个月。不过我仍然认为那段经历很棒，它给了我时间从大学经历中舒缓下来，并完成了从
a trainee clinical psychologist to a qualified one. So yes, if you are coming to the end of your training, I would still suggest it's quite good to have a little bit of downtime in between those two roles if you can. So we have had a whistle-stop tour through the eight ways and more that I have failed in psychology. I hope this has been really interesting for you to listen to as it helped you reflect on your own journey on the things that might not have gone to plan for you. Please do bear in mind the aspiring psychologist collective and the clinical psychologist collective, because there are many more experiences of people talking about failure and things not working out for them well there.
实习临床心理学家向合格心理学家的身份转变。所以，是的，如果你的培训即将结束，我仍然建议，如果条件允许的话，在这两个角色之间留出一点休息时间还是挺不错的。以上就是我们对我在心理学领域失败的八种及更多方式的旋风式回顾。我希望这对你来说是一次非常有趣的聆听体验，因为它帮助你反思了自己的旅程，以及那些可能没有按计划进行的事情。请记住“有志心理学家集体”和“临床心理学家集体”，因为那里有更多关于人们谈论失败以及事情进展不顺利的经历。
There will be links in my show notes where you can check those out. But yeah, I would love your thoughts about this. Please do come and let me know what you think to this episode in the free Facebook group, The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. That's over on Facebook. Please do rate and review this podcast on Apple and Spotifyify do consider leaving me a linkedin recommendation as well if we are connected on there that would be so gratefully received please do remember the ways that you can download some of my free resources as well going to my website www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk. If you go to the free resources section on the tab, you can download the free Declin Sci Guide, the free supervision contract, and the learning curve
我的节目备注中会有链接，大家可以去查看。但是，是的，我很想听听你对这件事的想法。请务必来免费的Facebook群组“由玛丽安·特伦特博士带领的有志心理学家社区”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent）告诉我你对这一集的看法。那个群组在Facebook上。请务必在Apple和Spotify上对这个播客进行评分和评论，如果我们已经在领英（LinkedIn）上建立了联系，也请考虑给我写一封领英推荐信，我会非常感激的。请记住，你也可以通过访问我的网站 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk 来下载我的一些免费资源。如果你点击选项卡上的“免费资源”部分，你可以下载免费的《去临床科学指南》（Declin Sci Guide）、免费的督导合同以及学习曲线
document as well, all of which gets great reviews. So thank you so much for being part of my world. I will look forward to catching up with you for the next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, which will be available for you from 6 a.m. on Monday. Take care. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner.
文件，所有这些都获得了极好的评价。非常感谢你们成为我世界的一部分。我期待着在下一期的《有志心理学家播客》中与大家见面，该节目将于周一上午6点准时上线。保重。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身旁，你将走上获得资质的道路。这就是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有志心理学家播客》。我叫亚娜，我是一名心理健康见习从业者。
I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现里面所有的不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣。通往那里的途径有那么多，而且没有成为其中一员的完美方式，这让我感到惊讶。这在某种程度上让我充满了信心，不，我并没有做错，并减轻了我自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐你看这本书，好让自己安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会把书放下了。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。